foreign
[Music]
yes I am Cindy sampius applications
technical lead for Leica and today we're
going to talk about the fundamentals of
hematoxylinineas and staining one of the
things that's been really fun with my
job is being able to interact with
customers as part of our cancer
Diagnostics process and one of the
biggest questions I get is about h e
so of course why do we do it right
um in this particular lecture we're
going to be looking at not only why we
do it we're going to talk about the
components
is it better to stain by hand or on a
platform we're going to suggest
protocols and then try to find the right
balance between your colors what do
artifacts look like and how can we
troubleshoot some of those how do I fix
these things and of course at the very
end we'll talk about whatever questions
you guys might have
so what is the h e well of course for
our routine diagnoses we're using this
as our Baseline this is what's getting
us started it really gives us a great
opportunity to look at the cellular and
tissue structure in detail so whenever
your slide review is looking at a
particular tumor type whether it's
benign or malignant the stain intensity
is is one of the things that they're
going to look at to determine just how
bad things are in some cases when you're
talking about multiple chromosome
anomalies in a nucleus the more
hematoxylin it picks up is more DNA
that's present in that cell now at the
end of the day most of the folks
reviewing slides have their preferred
coloration palette some people like it
very very pink others like it very very
blue it just really depends on the end
user and what they're looking for and of
course how they were trained initially
but we're going to talk about quite a
bit of this today and ways to balance
that stain out to get that slide
reviewer the exact coloration that
they're needing for their Diagnostics
so we have four basic components we have
our hematoxylin our differentiator which
of course is going to adjust the
coloration of your hematoxylin bluing
which is going to change the hematin
from that reddish color to the blue
color we're used to and of course eosin
which is our cytoplasmic stain
so hematoxylin is of course an
acidophilic diet which means it's acid
loving so it's going to stain anything
in your nucleus which of course includes
your DNA and your RNA there's a lot of
different types of hematoxylin out there
and each one has a slightly different
coloration appearance historically we
used to make all these things in our
Laboratories so you would have your
hematoxylin powder and you'd mix it up
now the challenge with that was making
sure that if I made hematoxylin this
week and you made hematoxylin next week
that we would get the nice balance there
and our preparation techniques could
influence exactly how that colors look
so depending on who's making it you're
going to have a stronger intensity or a
weaker intensity so the manufacturer
commercially of the hematoxylins stain
whichever one you choose to use has
really made that quality nice and
standardized so you don't see those
variations based on preparation
now when you think about hematoxylin
oxidation of it actually is going to
produce hematin which is the actual dye
in the stain and you can actually see
this by looking at the top of your
hematoxyl and if you have it in a dish
you'll actually start to see it have
almost a holographic appearance on top
it reminds me of the sheen you see with
E coli that's a sign that your
hematoxylin is being oxidized now one of
the ways we stabilize our hematoxylin is
by adding a mordant and that gives the
ability of the hematin to attach to an
anion something like iron aluminum is
another popular one that we use and it
helps it just helps stabilize it
hematoxylens are usually designed or
classed by whichever mordant they're
using so like we said previously the
Morton is actually going to strengthen
the positive ionic charge of the hematin
so it's going to Aid in the bonding of
the hematin to the anionic tissue
component which of course is going to be
your chromatin your DNA RNA now because
we're using different mortens that is
going to influence the final color of
the stain components and those changes
are very very subtle across the board
but if you have a particular preference
you will notice the difference between
mayor's hematoxylin for example and
heresimotoxally
so the most common one that we use in
routine histology is going to be your
aluminum ammonium sulfate this is
basically going to cause a nuclei to
stain red in color until we rinse it
with a weekly Basics solution I.E our
blowing solution and it's going to
change it to the more familiar blue
color that you're used to seeing
heresy metaxalin is the most commonly
used Alum hematoxylin and it can be used
for Progressive staining and regressive
staining of cytology specimens as well
it tends to provide a little bit clearer
nuclear detail and one of the things
though that you should know about it is
that it can be best differentiated with
a mild acid as opposed to using
Hydrochloric acid which is a very strong
acid historically we would use that you
would do one dip of the slide into your
hydrochloric acid differentiator and
you'd have to immediately get it into
water if you had it in there for two
seconds you could potentially completely
decolorize the slide of course we want
to avoid that so the mild acids with
your hair sumotoxin is going to make
that change a lot more subtle and give
you as much control as you could
possibly want in order to make sure you
get just the right color that you're
looking for and of course herosimotoxin
is an alcohol-based stain
another one of our hematoxylens that
we're very familiar with of course is
Mayor cemetoxylin it's another Alum
hematoxylin and it can be used both
progressively and regressively just like
our Harris it's also used as a nuclear
counter stain for many special stains
and IHC it works really well in that
scenario it doesn't give you too much
glue and it doesn't tend to stay in
other count of other components of the
cells and when it's used as a counter
stain
um
we want to see the nuclei and of course
then we'll get a blue the the slide
without using any differentiator because
we really don't we're not concerned
about removing any excess hematoxylin at
this point and it is a water-based stain
as well
galcumatoxylon is another one of the
what I consider to be the big three it's
an it's an Alum hematoxylin
um it's often used Progressive or
regressive and you can get it in lots of
different concentrations uh
predominantly we'll go one two and three
it is typically used for cytology stains
but sometimes folks will use that in
histology as well it's made with water
and ethylene glycol so the oxidation of
the stain is prevented over months
because of this and it just makes it
more stable than herosomatoxylin now the
nature of gills is that it is there is
some extra nuclear staining that may
occur so this is where your
differentiator can be really important
for getting rid of that extra staining
and mucine and even other adhesives on
the slide can actually stain blue in the
background so you will see some more
background stain that you would be
experiencing with some of the other
hematoxylens out there
foreign
there are quite a few other ones out
there that use iron salts is important
but they're usually in special stains
this is because they generally will
demonstrate more tissue structures than
the Alum hematoxylins so you can see
things like myelin or elastin fibers and
of course one of the best known out
there is weigers which we use in the
verhoff van diesen stain or elastic
stain
now the differentiator we've talked
about that just a little bit what this
is basically doing is it's allowing you
to be able to selectively remove stain
from tissues to get the coloration that
you're comfortable with so when you're
talking about hematoxylin hydrochloric
acid was used historically of course
it's a very rapid differentiator acetic
acid or citric acid are the ones that
are mild acids those are going to be for
a much more controlled differentiation
and those are the ones you're going to
commonly see in Laboratories while
hydrochloric acid was the standard it's
really started to become more
fashionable I guess to use a milder acid
because we are starting to use these
things on
platforms automated staining instruments
that sort of thing and you're going to
get a much gentler dye removal with that
you know automated staining has really
brought some amazing uh opportunities
into the laboratory for increases in
quality and production because we are
able to do the same thing over and over
again because you have those you know
robotic arms on there it makes it very
easy for your checks to load rack
the instrument takes off does its thing
and now you've got your text free to do
other things in the laboratory
so this site is actually a really
interesting one this one was not had any
differentiation at all and if you notice
there is like a Purple Haze in the
background and the the tissue itself
this is tonsil actually looks almost a
little blurred now in this case I am
using charge slides so you can see in
the lower right and left hand corner of
the slide itself there are little plus
signs indicating that they are charged
all that means is that the
the slides are going to have the tissue
adhere much more strongly your
differentiator would be using preferably
a mild acid in this case 30 seconds will
get rid of this blue background for you
that's easily if you go up to a minute
now you're going to actually start being
able to pull just a little bit of color
out of the nuclei so if you have over
stained it you can see where you know
you have a little bit more room to play
if you want to pull out more color or
not but 30 seconds is going to be the
the minimum in order to get rid of all
this blue background that we're seeing
here on this charge slide
now differentiation uh things like colon
for example which you can see in this
image depending on what you're looking
at and who's looking at it of course you
can notice that the goblet cells here
are just very with the hematography so
depending on what you're looking for are
some folks that make these types of GI
sounds and
physical yeah that's really important so
they do that to be people and there's
more differentiation
come to a progressive stain and that way
you'll be able to capture this uh the
blue of this Muse in in the goblet cells
now let's take a look at bluing reagents
so one of the most common ones out there
is Scott's tap water certainly there are
a wide variety of commercially available
blowing agents out there that you can
get to use in your laboratory but they
all function in the same way in that
they are a mildly basic solution that's
going to change that hematoxylin from
the red
to the traditional blue color that we're
used to seeing microscopically
and in this slide you can see the impact
of bluing so you'll notice a nice
distinctive line here where I dipped a
slide in part way you can see how the
the top of this of the piece of tonsil
is actually that purpose
I'm gonna try this again
here's a great example of how bluing
works so if you take a look at this
piece of tonsil here you're seeing nice
delineated line here the top half of the
slide hasn't actually been exposed to
the bluing agent but the bottom half has
and this is one of those things in your
protocols you're going to see that the
bluing is typically about a minute
mostly that's to accommodate movement of
the robotic arms on any of the standards
that are out there on the market but the
thing to know with that is I literally
dip this slide in and pulled it right
back out and you can just see after one
one to two second exposure to the uh the
Scots tap water it made a nice blue
color here on the slide
all right moving on to Edison so of
course Eason is the most commonly used
counter stain this is what's going to
distinguish your connective tissue your
cytoplasm from your nuclei it's
generally going to be pink and there are
different shades of pink depending on
what type of tissue fiber it's staining
so esmy of course is the most common
form of this and it's you can make it
both with water as a base or alcohol as
a base and just a small amount of acetic
acid added to it will also sharpen that
detail in your eosin it's really kind of
nice especially if your eosin is weak
just add a drop of acetic acid to it and
that should perk it right back up
eosin with flaxine is another common
mixture that we'll see when it comes to
eosin there are a lot of folks that
really enjoy the how it enhances the
Reds on their H E's
now when you're talking about cytology
there are other mixtures so in the case
of Eason we talk about ea50 ea65 these
are going to add a little bit of light
green yellowish and Bismarck Brown to
the eosin so when you look at a cytology
slide for example a pap smear you'll see
the teals blues pinks all of those
shades of color and all of that's coming
from your eosin
so just adding those two exercises
really what's going to make the
difference and of course the
concentration of the eosin is determined
by the designation of whether it's ea50
or ea65 which is going to have the most
esny added to it
well now diseasin really need to be
differentiated well of course the right
answer is yes a graded alcohol most
commonly 95 some folks will go as low as
70 percent alcohol and that's ideal to
remove any of the excess eosin that may
be in the tissue so what you'll be able
to see is the three different shades of
pink because when you have too much
eosin just like with too much
hematoxylin if you don't get some of
that excess out then the whole thing is
just going to be a very Bland one color
and of course that's not what we're
looking for right higher grades of
alcohol can also be used following eosin
but remember it's the water that's doing
the differentiation for you that's
what's going to pull out that excess
pink so if you go straight from eosin to
100 that's going to impact your
coloration
so what's better should we stand the
stuff by hand or should we use the
platform
well I can tell you with somebody who
has done a lot of staining by hand over
the years the platform has just improved
in my opinion the quality and the
quantity of work that we're able to get
through in the laboratory for one thing
your staining is going to be very
consistent it's going to be reproducible
of course your technologists Hands-On
time they can go off and do the other
things that may need to be done in the
laboratory
now there are some concerns about
potentially longer protocol times and
back in the day we used to say well I
have to have a 25 minute h e stain and
we were putting a focus in my opinion on
the wrong thing when you're looking at a
platform you can have 10 12 racks in
process at the same time so your
protocol length may be 50 minutes
but you're going to constantly have
material coming off of your stainer
whereas when we were doing things by
hand back in the day it was oftentimes a
lot easier to have just one or two racks
stating at the same time so you didn't
have five or six timers going off you
know all over the place this made it a
lot easier so the other thing that's
really nice too is you're much much
more able to follow your reagent
management and make sure that your
reagents are refreshed after a specified
amount of time and a specified a number
of slides or runs going through them
foreign
so when we look at protocols
um this is usually where folks struggle
and the reason I say that is everybody
has their own preference of what they
want to see under the scope
what's the shortest possible time I can
get especially when you're looking on
the clinical side of things turnaround
time is huge and that's usually one of
the things that kind of trips people up
a little bit because again when you're
talking about platforms you're talking
about having you know many things
happening at the same time as opposed to
just one or two racks at the same time
we want to reduce those touch points but
then depending on what you're doing how
many touch points are there actually and
is the cost of doing it on a platform
actually worth it depending on what it
is you're doing it may not be worth it
um in most cases it is but you know it
just depends on your particular
laboratory and what your uh your your
end game is
so remember at the end of the day we
have we want to have good quality and
reproducible results we want it to be
cost effective and honestly that's going
to be the biggest concerns from from
most Laboratories is the quality and of
course the overall cost
so what kind of protocols do we want to
run well there are generally three
different types uh Progressive which
means there's no differentiation step it
goes hematoxylin water bluing water
alcohol eosin
now modified regressive or Progressive
depending on you know if your glass is
half empty glasses half full person
there is a differentiation step utilized
however the only purpose of that
differentiation step is to get rid of
the blue background it's not going to
impact your nuclear detail at all and of
course regressive staining means we're
going to overstain with our hematoxylin
then we're going to use that acid to
gently bring back and remove that
background but also remove any excess
dye from the nuclei
so uh general rules when you're looking
at protocols uh your h e you want to
have your d-wax set to get rid of the
paraffin then you're going to hydrate it
that's usually done after going from
xylene to a pure alcohol to a grated
alcohol to water of course then our
hematoxylin differentiator Bluing
now we're going to start to introduce
alcohol back in so we can do our eosin
step
then once it comes out of using we're
going to dehydrate it go starting
usually with a grated alcohol going to
Pure alcohol and then for our clearing
step moving into xylene toluene or some
other aliphatic hydrocarbon solvent and
then we'll go to cover slipping
um the thing you remember with this too
is whatever you're using for your
clearing that's often to be the best
reagent that you use in your cover
slipper or if your ma if you're manually
cover slipping you want to make sure
that's going to be compatible with
whatever mounting media you choose to
use
the thing that's nice about this basic
protocol is it's really easy to
reproduce and your reagents are going to
be resilient enough to a large to allow
for a large number of slides to go
through before your reads need to be
changed that is so huge especially if
you're a laboratory where you're running
a thousand slides every day you want to
know that your reagents and your setup
is going to be able to tolerate that
much workload
so when we look at dewaxing and
hydrating while xylene is going to be
the most common solvent at least in the
United States we use it uh pretty much
exclusively or some type of xylene
substitute there are lots of other
things that you can use in its place
um some folks use toluene of course we
talked about xiline substitutes there
are things with citric oils in them like
citrus salt limoline those are all
different solvents the thing is you want
to make sure that whatever you are using
you're going to be able to tolerate the
slight volume that you're putting
through the reagent and you know these
things are all materials that are going
to have to have special waste just like
xylene now depending on on where you're
at those rules may vary slightly but by
the end of the day they really are
important for uh to understand exactly
what your local regulations are
regarding waste of any of those solvents
now once the paraffin has been removed
during the dewaxing step it's great
because now you can go into your your
alcohols and
then your water and then move on for the
rest of your staining the water washes
at the end of your grated alcohol is
what's actually going to finish that
rehydration and it's getting it ready
for the hematoxylin
so depending on which hematoxylin you
use you want to make sure that there's
plenty of time to get whatever
coloration you're looking for
so once you've got to that sweet spot
where you're like this is what I like
now the slide's going to be rinsed
that's essentially going to stop the
process and it's just going to remove
any excess stain then if you want to
differentiate your slide you can
certainly do that and then even control
it even more by
how long you leave it in that
differentiator keep in mind this is also
going to include your background
staining so you do want to make sure
that if you are going to use a
differentiator keep that in the back of
your mind that any additives you may
have added to your water bath some folks
use albumin some folks you stay on or if
you're using charge glass slides all of
those things are going to pick up your
hematoxylin to some extent so your
differentiator here is going to be
certainly something to consider while
you're while you're doing this and of
course once you're done with the
differentiation the Water Rinse is going
to stop that now you're going to go into
your bluing you can use other buffers
Scott's tap water is one of the most
common ones it's very easy to make and
it's not going to be something that's
going to necessarily have as big of an
impact on quality as say not being able
to mix your own hematoxylin correctly so
just keep that in mind as well
but it is going to change that reddish
cast to the desired blue as we saw in
the previous slides
all right well before we had Edison of
course we want to make sure we use that
95 alcohol to get that sample ready to
accept this alcohol-based dye
what's really fun about ESN is you can
adjust that coloration just with minor
time changes this season is
Houston's amazing in that it will turn
anything pink very very quickly and if
you've ever made hematoxylin from Powder
you know that that powder is finer than
confectioners sugar and that said if you
get it on anything you may not see it
right away but as soon as water hits it
it turns pink
when you are staining
when I optimize slides for customers I
will do anything as low as 15 minutes
generally up to one minute and I'll make
those changes in 15 second increments
any
shorter or shorter than that you're
probably not going to get get enough of
a difference to be able to go ah if you
do it too long then you're going to go
from light pink to extraordinarily
bright pink and that is
that can be painful on the eyes if
you're not used to seeing that the
edocent of course is differentiated
typically with a 95 ethanol it's going
to stop the staining process some folks
will use a 50 or 70 percent it just
depends again on what you want to do the
more water in that alcohol following the
eosin is going to pull out more of that
pink color for you so if you're tending
to over stain with your eosin you can
use a 50 70
those will pull that water out excuse me
pull out the ESN because they have such
a high water content normally like I
said we would do 95 percent of ethanol
and then you're going to go from that to
a pure alcohol and then of course to
your clearing so that you can get that
slight cover slipped and ready to view
let's talk a little bit about solvents
there's a lot of different choices out
there for your dewaxing and dehydrating
of course here in the US we tend to use
xylene that's our most common but that's
not to say there certainly aren't others
out there that are worth using some
places like to use toluene and then of
course we have the wide variety of
xilate substitutes that are out there
the thing to know about xylene
substitutes generally speaking they're
going to be a lot less tolerant to water
so if you have ambient humidity you're
going to start to see decreases in
quality one of the things you may notice
is if there is water in your
clearance and it goes to coverslip in a
few days you might notice a pink Haze
shifting across your slide that's
actually that water that was captured in
that clearance actually pulling the heat
the eosin out and you're starting to see
that drift across the slide
of course with any of these substitutes
they are going to have the same waste
disposal requirements so keep in mind
not only are you getting a product that
you can't use as long but you're going
to have to dispose of it the same way
and that can be extremely costly there
may not be a compatible mounting media
out there for that solvent citrus-based
solvents which are my personally my
least favorite those are things that can
actually because they're so aromatic can
actually cause reagent sensitivities in
folks and I've seen this in Laboratories
where after working with them
for a few months
folks will start to get migraines around
things that they wouldn't have not uh
wouldn't have otherwise been bothered by
which is to me is kind of sad I like the
idea of what's behind it but at the end
of the day it's not necessarily the bus
fit that doesn't mean don't use it it's
just that's been my experience
so there was a lot of different
protocols out there I have my personal
preference of course you see this here
on the slide I try to keep it very very
simple you do want to make sure that
your slides are dry so you can always
add an oven step if you want to the oven
step
um you know 15 minutes at 60 degrees is
fine we can we'll talk a little bit
about
some of the artifacts that you can see
and what causes them one of those things
is can potentially be that oven step but
you can see here
um you have a
uh our xylene xylene 100 195 and we go
right into a wash station or hematoxylin
and then all the way back out and again
the back end is essentially the reverse
of the front end 95 100 100 xylene
xylene out now some of these steps I do
keep is exact and the reason for that is
of course you don't want your
hematoxylin to potentially be in there
longer than four minutes if four minutes
is your sweet spot for your color same
thing is true for your differentiator
this is a very key component bluing most
folks just make it exact because it's a
staining component it's not as nearly as
critical as having your differentiator
hematoxylin and then of course when you
get to your eosin we want that to be
exact but we also want that first 95 and
that first 100 following it to be exact
because the 95 has water in it so if you
have it in there for a minute and your
standard builds in tolerances to allow
racks to continuously be moving through
what will happen is it stay in there
longer which means it's going to pull
more eosin out now because your rack
coming out of that 95 is going to go
into that first 100 ethanol there is
going to be some water carried over just
because the slides aren't coming out of
that 95 dry so I make that step
generally exact as well for the same
reason to reduce the potential for any
bleeding of the eosin
so balance of course is really important
we want to get the color quality that
we'd like but we also want to make sure
that we get the balance of the blue and
the pink what's really interesting is
you can see in this Slide the difference
two minutes of hematoxylin for the
sample on the left versus four minutes
for the sample on the right now I can
also have fun with this by playing with
my eosin by increasing my ESN time yes
everything will be a little bit darker
but I can play with my two hematoxyl and
eosin colors because they do play off of
each other so what will happen is if
your pink is really bright it's
naturally going to make the blue of your
nuclei seem a little bit lighter and the
other way around if your nuclei are
super dark your Eason may look a lot
lighter in color underneath the scope
and it's just because of the balance
simply doing things like if you want
your eosin to be brighter maybe dialing
back the nuclear stain just a smidge and
by that I mean 30 seconds to a minute
might make all the difference that you
need to get that eosin to the brightness
that you like without compromising your
nuclear detail
so the other thing that's kind of fun to
think about too is when you're looking
at your stain quality looking at things
grossly is not always your best friend
so I always always recommend folks
review their slides under the scope
before they decide whether the intensity
is appropriate as you can see here I've
got a nice piece of tonsil followed by a
piece of lung and then a piece of fatty
breast tissue notice that those all look
like wildly different when it comes to
how much hematoxylin was picked up of
course a lot of that is going to be due
to the tonsil being highly cellular with
very little cytoplasm of course your
lung tissue has a lot of Open Spaces in
it so it makes it look like that pink is
hardly there right and then when you
look at the fatty breasts it's even more
difficult to see any nuclei there at all
those are all stained at the exact same
protocol the exact same hematoxyl
anineos and stainings however the
cellular components themselves are
driving the differences in Gross
appearance so we want to be thoughtful
of that if we are making a decision
about whether we like something if we
think it's the right colors or not
always go microscopically because
grossly can throw you off
should I run a control slide I always
recommend that you do
now I'm a big fan of sausage blocks
those are analogous to micro arrays
except they're way cheaper to make I
like to use things like tonsil tonsil is
great because it's highly cellular very
low cytoplasm so you're really going to
get the nice intense blue colon of
course is fabulous it has the a lot of
cytoplasm you can also get muscle fibers
and some fat connected to that as well
so again you're going to have a range of
cell types to be able to look at
microscopically and of course skin is
nice a dermatologists oftentimes will
have a particular color scheme that
they're going for and if that's what
you're studying in your lab whoever is
going to be reviewing your slides these
are the three things that are going to
give you an idea in one simple slide of
how your stain is going to work across a
variety of different sample types so I
strongly recommend using this as a
control is it absolutely necessary to
use these three skin types no uh feel
free to make something a sausage block
make it your own if you're predominantly
doing liver and stomach
then make your control
um consistent with that that way you'll
know exactly what you should be
expecting
so optimization is a question that I
hear about a lot how do I perform it
I know normally when I'm doing
optimization for my customers I will
take a look at their slides what they
currently have and I'll ask them do you
like this
um sometimes they say yep sometimes they
say no and then I have to unpack exactly
what it is that they don't like about it
what I'll do and like I said on that
previous with the sausage block
um I'll I'll pick breast colon skin
tonsil and uterus because again that
covers a nice wide variety of different
uh sample types and different nuclear to
cytoplasmic configurations
so that said I will also then grab my my
preferred stain I will stain
uh my my sample slide with what they
already have and then I will tweak it
with whatever stains I'm bringing in to
work with the customer and I will use
that and try to match some if the
customer is like I have no idea I just
want something better than this I will
usually sit down and ask them what does
that mean for you and then if they want
it to be more blue if they want it to be
more pink
depending on you know what direction
they want to go with it I'm very easily
able to help them adjust their stain to
get exactly what they're looking for
color wise
typically when I'm doing an optimization
I will increase or decrease my
hematoxylin by 30 seconds and of course
my ESN by 15 seconds
if you really want to get nuanced about
it you can even go further and adjust
your time of your differentiator just
adjusting it from one minute to a minute
and 30 seconds is going to make your
hematoxylin just a little bit less pale
but for simplicity's sake you know we'll
go with just increasing or decreasing
hematoxylin and then increasing and
decreasing your eosin
so when I am doing this I will have
several different sets of slides I will
put the put my different stain
variations I'll have that in a little
table and I assign randomization codes
part of the reason I do that is because
there's a lot of folks that
I think they know what four minutes and
hematoxylin looks like on every possible
hematoxylin out there and of course
that's not the case so to get them away
from trying to assign numbers to things
what I like to do is just give them
slides and say tell me what you like
and by not giving them any other
information except here's your slides
tell me what you think that forces them
to go strictly on what they like to see
and not necessarily adding in
any other
is my hematoxylin long enough do I want
my ears in to be shorter whatever any of
those extra variables will be it makes
it very very simple now one of the
challenges I will tell you that I see
from time to time is water quality and
water quality will make four minutes in
hematoxylin
look very different depending on what
the problem is with your water quality
so again this is why when I do my
optimization I give them randomization
codes and I have them write down what
they like and what they don't like and
then we go back from there and adjust it
and what's really great is it makes it
so much less stressful when you're
working with whoever is reviewing the
slides directly and it just simplifies
it for them and it makes it so much
easier for you
all right so let's talk a little bit
about how these things are supposed to
look under the microscope
all right if we take a look at this
slide you'll see a nice piece of normal
lymph node what's really interesting
about this one is it doesn't look like
there's very much easing in it at all of
course keep in mind that our nuclear to
cytoplasmic ratio is very different here
than what we would see on a
well-differentiated squamous cell for
example with a tiny nucleus and lots of
cytoplasm but you can also see on the
nuclei are very clear we have some
stromal cells in here of course some red
blood cells everything looks nice and
crisp
all right now this is really nice piece
of placenta and as you can see here we
have some variation in our easons we do
have a lot more cytoplasm here so the
nuclei are going to take a back seat a
little bit to the pink but you'll see
that we again have different colors of
the pink in here so it's really
showcasing that cytoplasmic detail
so how do we get everything balanced
we'll take a look at this slide here we
have a nice section of lymphocytes on
the top with muscle fibers underneath
this is again where that balance is very
important and why you want to make sure
that your control slides represent a
variety of tissues and the top half of
the slides it looks like we only stained
it with hematoxylin and of course that's
because there really isn't any cytoplasm
around your lymphocytes those are very
very small cells of course with almost
no cytoplasm as we go down to the muscle
fibers though you'll notice that
cytoplasm is the predominant component
here so even though we still have
periodic nuclei of course within the
cells you can see that we have and the
colors are exactly the same between the
lymphocytes coloration of the nuclei and
the nuclei down here in the muscle
fibers but notice how rich that pink is
with this particular sample we would be
able to dim the light a little bit and
you'd actually be able to see the
refractile nature of those muscle fibers
but again this is one of those things
where it's really important to
understand just how that balance can
make a difference depending on how many
nuclei you have versus how much
cytoplasm
and this one is really interesting this
is an adenocarcinoma of the colon and
you can see where we have some normal
nuclei and then we get right into the
abnormal ones now the malignant nuclei
uh
very irregular in shape and you can
notice that because of the different
amount of DNA now that's in these you're
going to see some different coloration
as you go through all those nuclei but
for foundation we have some pink in here
with some red blood cells we have some
stroma and of course we have some
lymphocytes around here so that's one of
the things that you can always use as a
guidepost take a look at the new the
normal nuclei that are in your piece of
tissue and you can be able to see a
pretty strong difference between those
and your malignant nuclei and it's
really profound depending on what you're
looking at
looking at this one now this is actually
a a piece of tonsil now this one is
incredibly pink in this particular case
the preference of the reviewer was to
have a much lighter nuclear stain and
really enhance the eosin in the
background now for me personally I don't
care for this balance but I'm not the
one that's reviewing the slide so this
is certainly not wrong
by any means but in my opinion it's not
ideal so this is where you want to make
sure that your slide reviewer has
the most say and what they want to see
microscopically
all right so now let's talk about how
when things are not what we want to see
let's talk about water quality
so you can see slight a here and slide B
slide a and slide B are from the same
block but they look very very different
water quality is often an issue I see in
the field and of course
one side it could be very very acidic
the other side it could be very very
basic when your water is very acidic
that's not going to negatively impact
your hematoxylin because essentially
you're taking acid water and putting it
into an acid dye and by keeping that pH
appropriate in your hematoxylin you're
not going to deplete it
now when you come out of hematoxylin
though and you go into that wash
following it that acid water is actually
going to decolorize your slide a little
bit before you put it in your
differentiator so every subsequent water
wash after that is going to pull more
and more hematoxylin out if your water
is basic now what's going to happen is
you have a higher pH liquid carrying
over into your hematoxylin that's going
to weaken your hematoxylin and it's not
going to allow it over time to continue
the nice coloration that you would be
used to if you had stable water so your
first slides of the day may look great
but as the day progressives and more and
more of the the
alkaline water gets added into your
hematoxylin just by normal carryover
you're actually going to start to see
your hematoxylin lighten up a little bit
so this is one of those things that if
you're getting inconsistent staining and
you're not sure why the pet store and
water testing strips is a great way to
just test your water and kind of a
ballpark of where you're at this doesn't
have to be dead exact 7.1 measurements
we're talking is it 7.5 is it nine
that's what's going to help you with
this particular
artifact is to make sure that your water
is stable that will give you stable
staining overall
now when folks bake their slides which I
completely agree it's it's great it
helps you dry your slide quickly it
actually melts that paraffin a little
bit so when it goes into that first
xylene you have a nice warm slide that
that wax is going to come out very very
easily
problem is some folks try to do too much
with the heat putting it in a really hot
oven and there's a lot of water
underneath it it's actually going to
vaporize that
water through the nuclei which of course
are proteins and it's going to create
nuclear artifacts like you see here
which we call soap bubbles now when
you're looking at a prostate tumor the
downside to this is that not only are
these nuclei very very fragile nuclear
changes like that can actually be
indicative of some malignancy such as
thyroid cancer one of the trademarks is
to have a nuclear hole in it like you
see here the downside is if your patient
has a normal thyroid but it goes through
the temperatures like this and ends up
causing nuclear bubbling it can actually
create a false positive because you'll
be misinterpreting what would normally
be considered standard diagnostic
criteria for a particular tumor so you
want to bake with care is the bottom
line here and there is no going back
from this once you've gotten air bubbles
there's no way to fix this unfortunately
now some of the things that we use when
we're doing our stains can leave pigment
behind formal and pigment is is one of
the big things you can see some of it
here
if you're using good quality reagents
it's not as much of an issue but some of
the poorer quality ones some of the poor
quality hematoxylons if they're not
filtered you can actually start to see
some of these pigments in here your
fixatives can also impact that back in
the day we used to use zankers which was
a combination of mercuro chloride and
potassium dichromate and oftentimes we
would see this type of particulate don't
let those things uh dissuade you from
making your diagnosis these things can
unfortunately show up and they have in
in some cases trip Folks up so just to
be aware that they are out there
cautery artifact is another issue that
we see
um with this you'll notice how one end
is kind of blackened and kind of fried
and all the nuclear detail there is is
gone this is again something that we'll
see during processing one of the things
that can also cause that is if you take
your biopsies out and you like to use
sponges or wraps make sure that you make
those sponges and wraps wet with
whatever your fixative is never ever
ever put a sample onto dry paper towel
and then try to wrap it up in that
little piece of wrap and put it in a
cassette because what that's going to do
is pull all the liquid out of your
sample and you'll actually start to see
some of these edges like this
um this is also can be caused by when
the sample is collected if you're using
a cautering iron to collect your sample
this will also happen as well so just
keep that in mind as you are working
through your hnes when you do see stuff
like this consider the tissue trauma on
the front end before it even got to the
stainer could be causing your problem
let's talk about 4G paraphernalization
so in this slide you can see we have
some irregular staining we have some
light pink here at the bottom darker
pink toward the top this is a sign that
your slide has not been appropriately
de-paraphanized
so what can cause it well if your
reagents are really really dirty your
solvents maybe you've been using them a
lot and you haven't had a chance to
refresh them maybe you don't have enough
time in your solving I prefer to keep
mine in around two minutes and I have
two changes of xylene and that works
really nicely for getting out all of my
paraffin but if you're finding that
that's not working for you there's no
harm in adding a third violin if you
want to
um I've just again try to minimize the
amount of waste on my instrument and
that's part of the way that I do that is
by having my two steps also keep in mind
if you're not drying your slides long
enough before you stain them
and you put them on there the water is
going to prevent the xylin from actually
getting to that paraffin so the best way
to prevent this from happening is change
your reagents regularly
and of course make sure your slides are
nice and dry before you put them on the
center
poor dehydration
so in this slide we can see there's some
excess water left behind after we've
gone through our dehydration steps on
the way to cover slipping and you can
see I have an arrow pointing toward it
here in the photo but you can definitely
see there's water different spots here
so what can actually cause that
if your laboratory is very very humid
you can actually get some that ambient
humidity into your xylenes
of course the other thing is if you're
not changing your xylenes often enough
you can actually have water carry over
from when it leaves Eason to the 95 to
the 100s you'll actually start to get
some water going across that so that's
why we do have recommended changes for
your reagents the biggest way to reduce
this problem make sure that your
reagents are changed regularly we just
want to make sure that we don't have any
water in anything if your lab feels like
it's very humid you can always purchase
a hygrometer that's with a G and that
will tell you what your room humidity is
most staining equipment doesn't have a
really tight range for humid conditions
so you're generally going to be able to
have quite a bit of leeway but if you
want to just track your humidity in your
lab that's one way to do that and it'll
certainly help prevent issues like this
one
and as I mentioned before if there's
water in your sample
you will start to see over time as your
slides hang out in there you know when
you put them in storage you'll actually
see a pink cast shifting across the side
because that's the eosin coming out of
the tissue
it's actually kind of neat to see but it
also makes me sad when I see it
now we've all had those days where the
tissue comes off the processor and we go
to embed it and we know it's going to be
a rough day because it's super super dry
and crunchy
well in order to accommodate that
oftentimes will soak now I prefer my
processing to be amazing so that I don't
have to soak anything but you don't
always get what you want right so that
said if you are having to soak your
samples you want to do it and be
thoughtful about it
um now I can't say don't soak it longer
than five minutes because that's going
to vary depending on how dry your sample
is
but if you over soak and unfortunately I
do see this quite often you can actually
get some artifacts so notice on these
nuclei here this is actually uh colon
and you notice how we have no nuclear
detail at all they look kind of Cloudy
and kind of swollen
when you are rehydrating on your when
you're soaking when you're getting ready
to cut them unfortunately what will
happen is it will create these types of
artifacts which can cause you to lose
the nuclear detail that in some cases
can be so critical to diagnosis prostate
cancer is a great example of that
because it's not known for being
extremely hyperchromatic so when you do
lose that
that nuclear salt and pepper chromatin
that we would expect to see with the
swelling when we lose that detail that
can oftentimes negatively impact on how
we're doing our Diagnostics
now let's talk about some
troubleshooting
so most of the common h e related
artifacts are very simply correct
corrected first of all you always want
to use quality reagents so make sure
your stains are good quality your
ancillaries your alcohols and xylins
those are all of good quality and
periodically test your water uh you'd be
surprised how much heavy rainfall or
heavy snowfall can actually stir up the
groundwater and give you wide variations
in your uh your tap water
filter your stains is needed to avoid
floaters if you have a lot of staining
and processing of dry samples floaters
are always a risk it's always a great
idea to filter your stains just to make
sure that you do remove any of that
excess tissue or excess particulate that
can happen in your some of your lower
quality hematoxylins you want to filter
those to get that out so you don't see
that on your slides
career region containers if you're not
using them so if you're going home for
the evening you want to cover those you
don't want them to be evaporating you
don't want them to be negatively
impacted by your laboratory ambient
environment and you can always have a
hygrometer on hand to monitor humidity
they're very inexpensive and they're
pretty easy to get your hands on but
they're really helpful tool
maintain your instruments I can't stress
that enough doing good maintenance on
them having your annual PMS
those things are so critical to keeping
all of these things running smoothly for
you and of course
reach out to your vendor and get some
refresher training for your staff it's
really interesting some of the places
that I visit I do have team members that
don't get to spend as much time with the
instruments and then of course there's a
day when all of the other key users are
off and they have to go and use their
instrument and try to figure out how to
troubleshoot it when they may have
touched it once or twice throughout you
know a three-month period for example so
it's always good to give refresher
training for your staff and depending of
course on on your locality certification
does require so many continuing
education credits every year so it's
also a great opportunity to refresh your
staff with their instruments also the
basics of h e but to get them those
continuing education credits to maintain
certification
foreign
the dues
always run a QC slide make sure
everything's looking good if you change
out your hematoxylin go ahead and run
another QC slide we want to make sure
that that hematoxylin is performing to
the uh expectations of your team if you
change your ancillary reagents and you
want to change out your whole instrument
at once run a QC slide to make sure it
is all looking good but you should
always run one before your first rack of
tissues in the morning just to make sure
everything's looking good make sure that
you have good wash water on your
instrument this one is so important make
sure that your pH is where you need it
to be and that you have good water
pressure too low pressure can make your
slide rinse is ineffective or less
effective than they otherwise would be
do select a protocol that's going to
make sense for your slide reviewer make
sure that you're meeting their
expectations it's going to make your
life so much easier
always always use quality reagents and
of course filter your stains to reduce
particulate and floaters
the domes
do not rush your standing times there is
nothing worse than trying to push
something through and then having to
redo it again because there was water in
the xylem
the hematoxylin isn't dark enough always
take your time it'll save you time in
the big picture
don't overuse your reagents I know that
it might seem like
you're going to be saving a lot of money
if you
get just a few more slides but always
try to follow the manufacturer
recommendations for throughput because
if you try to push it it oftentimes can
come back and you'll slides will not
look as good as you wanted to
um I usually discourage folks I'm using
recycled reagents only because most
folks don't test those reagents for
Purity so if you're doing your ethanols
for example on a uh recycler and you're
not making sure that you're actually
getting 98 200 Purity you can actually
be adding water to your xylens because
remember on your dehydration step you're
going from a grated alcohol to a pure
alcohol to a solvent if that pure
alcohol is coming off your dehydrated
recycler and you think it's pure but
it's not now you're adding other
contaminants into your silence and
that's going to impede your coloration
and of course your cover slipping
and always always or I should say never
never neglect your staff make sure that
they have good training and you do could
do annual reviews for competency on
using your equipment very very important
it's it's amazing especially as as
hectic as it can be in the laboratory
um
if we don't get those Refreshers
sometimes maintenance kind of
goes to the Wayside a little bit and so
we definitely want to make sure that not
only is everyone comfortable but your
instrument is given the love it deserves
the bottom line a good h e is going to
keep your slide reviewers happy and it's
going to make sure that they have the
best possible foundation for diagnosis
whenever you're working on your agencies
you always want to make sure that your
colors look good and your slide
reviewers are getting exactly what they
need there's always a patient at the end
of whatever it is you're doing so we do
want to make sure that those
foundations are as optimal as they
possibly can be
one of the key takeaways as well is that
your stain is only going to be as good
as your processing if you're finding
that you can't achieve what you're
trying to do with your h e take a look
at your tissue processing and make sure
that it's as optimized as possible you
don't want to be having to soak samples
for a long period of time and of course
there's nothing worse than cutting into
a piece of fatty tissue laying it on
your water bath and watching it explode
because the center of that tissue hasn't
been appropriately infiltrated so please
keep these things in mind and you're
going to have the best possible h e
experience and your slide reveals will
be really really happy with you
thank you for attention today I really
appreciate you guys joining our webinar
if you have any questions please feel
free to share them now we'd like to open
it up for any thoughts comments that you
might have